This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Have you ever had one of those conversations where half the people in the room have a very strongly held opinion and the other half feel just as strongly in the opposite direction? This happened to me a few years ago. I was having dinner with friends in Washington, DC. Everyone was talking about some shocking news that had just come out. Tens of thousands of top secret documents from the National Security Agency or NSA had been leaked to journalists.
这里是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。你是否经历过这样的对话：房间里一半人持有非常坚定的观点，而另一半人则持有同样强烈的相反观点？几年前我就遇到过这种情况。当时我正在华盛顿特区和朋友们共进晚餐。每个人都在谈论刚刚爆出的惊人新闻。数万份来自国家安全局（NSA）的绝密文件被泄露给了记者。
Since at least 2008, the National Security Agency has been using secret technology to hack into secret and far-reaching and it's been going on for years. The government can compel a phone company to provide this metadata as it's called for millions of customers. The man who released all these documents was Edward Snowden, a computer security consultant at the NSA. The document's detailed extensive secret U.S. surveillance of people and governments across the globe.
至少从2008年起，国家安全局就一直在利用秘密技术进行黑客攻击，而且这种行为已经持续多年。政府可以强制电话公司提供数百万客户的所谓元数据。发布这些文件的男子是爱德华·斯诺登，一名国家安全局的计算机安全顾问。这些文件详细记录了美国在全球范围内对个人和政府进行的大规模秘密监视。
Edward Snowden believed that what the NSA was doing was wrong, and that the public had a right to know. I don't want to live in a world where everything that I say, everything I do, everyone I talk to, every expression of creativity or love or friendship is recorded. Fearing correctly that he was in the crosshairs of U.S. security agencies, Edward Snowden fled the United States and found refuge in Russia. Back at the dinner table with my friends that night, someone asked a simple question, Edward Snowden, hero or traitor.
爱德华·斯诺登认为国家安全局的做法是错误的，公众有权知情。我不希望生活在一个我所说的一切、所做的一切、与之交谈的每一个人、每一次创造力、爱或友谊的表达都被记录下来的世界里。由于担心自己成为美国安全机构的目标（事实证明他的担心是正确的），爱德华·斯诺登逃离了美国，并在俄罗斯找到了避难所。那天晚上回到餐桌旁，有人问了一个简单的问题：爱德华·斯诺登，是英雄还是叛徒？
One side of the dinner party was certain. This man was a hero. He had acted in the public interest and learning Americans to heavy-handed surveillance by their government. The rest of the group, they were equally certain. Edward Snowden was a trader who shares national security secrets that embarrass your country, and dangers the lives of US intelligence agents and your country, and dangerous the lives of US intelligence agents and service members, and then finds refuge in Russia, Vladimir Putin's
晚餐聚会的一方非常肯定。这个人是英雄。他为了公众利益采取了行动，提醒美国人注意政府的高压监视。而另一部分人则同样肯定。爱德华·斯诺登是一个叛徒，他分享了让国家蒙羞的国家安全机密，危及了美国情报人员和军人的生命，然后躲到了弗拉基米尔·普京的俄罗斯。
Russia. What fascinated me about this debate was how quickly people came to their conclusions, how certain they were that they were right. What explained it? Today, we explore what happens when two core moral values are pitted against each other. Loyalty vs. honesty. on hidden brain. Darwin Rocher grew up in Detroit, Michigan in the 1970s and 80s. His father was a millwright. He dismantled, repaired, and reassembled
俄罗斯。这场辩论让我着迷的是，人们得出结论的速度之快，以及他们对自己正确性的确信程度。是什么解释了这一点？今天，我们来探讨当两种核心道德价值观相互对立时会发生什么。忠诚与诚实。在《隐形大脑》节目中。达尔文·罗谢尔在20世纪70年代和80年代的密歇根州底特律长大。他的父亲是一名机械装配工。他负责拆卸、修理和重新组装
huge pieces of machinery in a steel factory. Darwin's mom stayed at home to raise him and a sister. She'd help them with their homework, give them life advice. She'd also whip up big family dinners every Sunday evening. My childhood was pretty good. I can't recall any really adverse childhood experiences that I went through as a as a kid and as well as a young adult in a teenager. So I had a pretty good pretty good lifestyle. I really enjoy being a kid.
钢铁厂里巨大的机械设备。达尔文的母亲则留在家中抚养他和妹妹。她会帮他们做作业，给他们生活建议。她每周日晚上还会精心准备丰盛的家庭晚餐。我的童年过得相当不错。我不记得在童年、少年或青年时期经历过什么真正糟糕的事情。所以我有一个相当不错的生活方式。我真的很享受童年的时光。
Darwin's parents were loving, kind, church-going folks. They tried to impress the right values on young Darwin. They try to impress the right values on young Darwin. Doing the right thing for the right reasons, being a person of honesty and integrity, doing the best you can, and doing the right the first time in everything that you do. When Darwin was around 12 years old, he violated his parents' moral code. One day he snuck into a neighbor's yard and picked some of her flowers. As he was walking home with his freshly assembled bouquet, the neighbor called his mom and told her what he'd done. My mom really got after me about doing that and she was telling me how important it is to respect other people's property. So the punishment or I guess the reward would be that I had to do yard service for her for the remaining summer at the cutter grass and everything like that. Darwin said this lesson taught him what kind of person he wanted to be. At home he became the model son. At school he got good grades.
达尔文的父母是充满爱心、善良且虔诚的教徒。他们试图将正确的价值观灌输给年幼的达尔文。他们试图将正确的价值观灌输给年幼的达尔文。为了正确的理由做正确的事，做一个诚实正直的人，尽你所能，在所做的每一件事中第一次就做对。当达尔文大约12岁时，他违反了父母的道德准则。有一天，他溜进邻居的院子里摘了一些花。当他拿着刚采好的花束走回家时，邻居给他的母亲打了电话，告诉了她他所做的事。我妈妈因为这件事狠狠地教训了我，她告诉我尊重他人的财产是多么重要。所以惩罚，或者我猜是补偿，就是我必须在剩下的夏天里为她做庭院服务，割草之类的活儿。达尔文说，这次教训让他明白了自己想成为什么样的人。在家里，他成了模范儿子。在学校，他成绩优异。
But when he was 16 he received a different kind of lesson. A lesson that taught him what kind of person he didn't want to be. He was driving to pick up his sister from school. Two friends were in the car with him, all of the boys were black. Suddenly, in his rearview mirror, Darwin saw the flashing lights of a police car. And so I didn't think anything of it because I've never had any negative encounters with law enforcement at all. There were four officers in the squad car. All of them got out. One approached Darwin. So the officer approached the driver's side door and he asked me for my driver's license.
但当他16岁时，他接受了另一种教训。一个让他明白自己不想成为什么样的人的教训。他当时正开车去学校接妹妹。车里还有两个朋友，男孩们都是黑人。突然，在后视镜里，达尔文看到了警车的闪光灯。我当时没多想，因为我从未与执法部门发生过任何负面冲突。警车里有四名警察。他们全都下了车。其中一人走向达尔文。警察走到驾驶座车门旁，向我要驾照。
Darwin knew his license was in the car, probably in the side pocket of the door. Something told him not to reach for it. So I said my driver's license is here, but I just don't know where it's located. And so at that point, he ordered all three of us out the car, and then he told us to put our hands on the trunk of the car, of my car, while they searched the interior of the vehicle. And then the officer walked back to me and said, hey, I found your driver's license,
达尔文知道驾照在车里，可能在车门的侧兜里。某种直觉告诉他不要去拿。所以我说我的驾照在这里，但我不知道具体在哪儿。就在那时，他命令我们三个人都下车，然后让我们把手放在车后备箱上，同时他们搜查了车内。接着，那名警察走回我身边说，嘿，我找到你的驾照了，
and he held it in his left hand, and he showed it to me. And I smiled because I was happy because I didn't know where it was at. And then he slapped me in the face very hard, and told me to wipe that smile off my face. He took his hand and did like a clamp around my throat, squeezing my Adam's apple. At one point, Darwin looked at the other three officers. And the other officers kind of, they were black males and they kind of just kind of shrugged
他左手拿着驾照，向我展示。我笑了，因为我很高兴，因为我之前不知道它在哪儿。然后他狠狠地扇了我一巴掌，叫我把脸上的笑容收起来。他用手掐住我的喉咙，挤压我的喉结。那一刻，达尔文看向其他三名警察。其他警察有点……他们是黑人男性，他们只是耸了耸肩，
away and I was kind of looking at them like, you know, are you gonna allow this to happen? Are you gonna allow someone to assault me? And I'm 16 years old, and I haven't done anything wrong. And so at that point, they kind of just kind of went along to get along and didn't do anything to intervene. And then they counted last year for about five minutes, but that five minutes I thought that they were actually going to kill me because he told me when he choked me, the only reason
走开了。我当时看着他们，心想，你们真的要允许这种事发生吗？你们要允许别人袭击我吗？我才16岁，我什么坏事都没做。所以当时，他们只是随波逐流，没有采取任何干预措施。他们在那儿待了大约五分钟，但这五分钟里，我以为他们真的会杀了我，因为他在掐我的时候说，我之所以
I won't kill you out here is because it's daylight. After the incident, Darwin thought about what had happened. He thought about the officer who had choked him, but he also thought about the other three officers who had watched and done nothing. Why did they hesitate to speak up? Did they not want to break ranks with their fellow officer? I was hoping to think maybe one of those officers would have the courage to stand forth and say, okay, this officer is out here assaulting teenagers and brought daylight for no crime whatsoever.
不在外面杀了你，是因为现在是白天。事件发生后，达尔文思考了发生的一切。他想到了那个掐他的警察，但也想到了其他三个袖手旁观的警察。他们为什么犹豫着不敢开口？他们是不想破坏与同事的统一战线吗？我当时希望也许其中一名警察会有勇气站出来说，好吧，这名警察在光天化日之下袭击青少年，而他们并没有犯任何罪。
The encounter left Darwin with a concussion, but the injustice of what had happened stayed with him long after the physical pain had eased. stayed with him long after the physical pain had eased. He sometimes asked himself what he would have done if he had been one of the three officers who had witnessed the assault. If a situation arose where he had to choose between loyalty and honesty, would he hesitate to speak up? He was soon to find out the answer. After a stint in the Air Force, Darwin eventually became a police officer and Detroit himself.
这次遭遇给达尔文留下了脑震荡，但事件带来的不公感在身体疼痛消退后依然久久挥之不去。在身体疼痛消退后依然久久挥之不去。他有时会问自己，如果他是那三名目睹袭击的警察之一，他会怎么做。如果出现必须在忠诚和诚实之间做出选择的情况，他会犹豫是否要说出来吗？他很快就会找到答案。在空军服役一段时间后，达尔文最终自己也成为了一名底特律警察。
He rose in the ranks and gained the respect of his fellow officers. Soon work in life began to blow together. Colleagues became friends. Darwin felt especially close to one of his scout partners. They'd go out and patrol together almost every day. I consider him a friend. He was at my house. I was at his house.
他步步高升，赢得了同事们的尊重。很快，工作和生活开始交织在一起。同事变成了朋友。达尔文觉得与其中一名巡逻搭档特别亲近。他们几乎每天都一起出去巡逻。我把他当作朋友。他去过我家。我也去过他家。
And he really taught me how to be a street officer. He taught me how to detect crime, drug narcotics, trafficking, those sort of things. He was a street cop and he was very good at his craft. On weekends, they'd watch sports together. They celebrated milestones with their families. He was just a good guy. When he would come on my house, I had a young child at that time. He would kind of ask me about the kid and ask me, did I need anything?
他真的教会了我如何成为一名街头警察。他教我如何侦查犯罪、毒品、贩运等这类事情。他是一名街头警察，而且非常精通自己的业务。周末，他们会一起看体育比赛。他们与家人一起庆祝人生中的重要时刻。他真是个好人。当他来我家时，我当时有个年幼的孩子。他会问我关于孩子的事，问我是否需要什么帮助。
Because I knew I was a new or officer. And he just kind of took on a big brother role for me in certain aspects. Darwin had another scout partner he was close to. For reasons that will become clear later in the story, we are not naming Darwin's fellow cops. Darwin felt he had a real bond with this second partner. He was more quiet, soft-spoken, a good partner.
因为我知道我是一名新警察。在某些方面，他就像我的大哥一样。达尔文还有另一位关系密切的巡逻搭档。出于故事后面会明朗的原因，我们不透露达尔文同事的名字。达尔文觉得他与这第二位搭档有着真正的纽带。他比较安静、说话温和，是个好搭档。
We were more adventurous when we worked together. We would go and investigate things on a deep level because we were anxious to get out there on the streets and we wanted just to patrol and have fun. There was a third colleague, Darwin, respected enormously. When they worked together, Darwin always felt he came away with a better understanding of what it meant to be a Detroit police officer. Me being a new officer, they kind of tell you, write a lot of tickets, get a lot of citations, get some stats, and he kind of explained to me that these tickets that you write these
我们一起工作时更具冒险精神。我们会深入调查事情，因为我们渴望走上街头，只想巡逻并享受乐趣。还有第三位同事，达尔文非常尊重他。当他们一起工作时，达尔文总是觉得他对成为一名底特律警察的意义有了更好的理解。作为一名新警察，他们会告诉你，多开罚单，多写传票，多搞点数据，而他向我解释说，你开的这些罚单对这些人来说
people have a you know a monetary impact adverse impact on them. He said you know it's okay to give out a warning. You know at certain times so is those intangibles that you didn't learn any academy on how to be a patrol officer for the city of Detroit. The brotherhood he formed with his officers gave Darwin a sense of security. The cops knew each other's families. When they were out on dangerous calls, Darwin felt like he could trust these men to watch his back to keep him safe. And of course, he knew he would do the same for them.
有金钱上的负面影响。他说，你知道，有时候给个警告是可以的。所以，这些是在警校里学不到的关于如何成为一名底特律巡逻警察的无形知识。他与同事们建立的兄弟情谊给了达尔文一种安全感。警察们了解彼此的家庭。当他们处理危险任务时，达尔文觉得他可以信任这些人来掩护他，保证他的安全。当然，他也知道自己会为他们做同样的事。
One night in 1998, the four men got together for a beer at a dive bar on the east side of Detroit. We had drinks, we talked about sports, we talked about police work, we talked about women, and things that people do at that age group. And then the conversation went in a new direction. One of his scout partners asked Darwin a question, do you want to make some money? And I said, well, of course, I mean, what do you want to do?
1998年的一天晚上，四个人聚在底特律东区的一家小酒吧喝啤酒。我们喝了酒，谈论体育，谈论警察工作，谈论女人，以及那个年龄段的人会做的事情。然后谈话转向了一个新的方向。他的一位巡逻搭档问了达尔文一个问题：你想赚点钱吗？我说，当然，我的意思是，你想做什么？
And he said, well, I got an idea. of course. I mean, what do you want to do?" And he said, well, I got an idea. The office had told Darwin about a bookie who had just been released from prison for tax evasion and illegal gambling. The bookie had stashed a million dollars in a safe at his house. And we're going to go in there, we're going to get it. And I know that you're a young officer and they don't pay well, you have a young child, and you can put some coins in your pocket. And it's just the one-time shot we go in, we go out, it's a one-day thing, and then we can be set for a very long time to come. It was like a plot of a movie. Darwin sat there, stupified.
他说，嗯，我有个主意。当然。我的意思是，你想做什么？那名警察告诉达尔文，有一个赌徒刚因逃税和非法赌博出狱。那个赌徒在他家的保险箱里藏了一百万美元。我们要进去，我们要把它拿走。我知道你是一名年轻的警察，工资不高，你还有一个年幼的孩子，你可以往口袋里塞点钱。这只是一次性的机会，我们进去，拿了就走，这是一天的事，然后我们就能在很长一段时间内衣食无忧了。这就像电影里的情节。达尔文坐在那里，惊呆了。
At first I thought it was a joke. I thought it was a high-very, very funny. But as the conversation continued, he started to draw a diagram of the target house and how we would approach this house. And I remember, Shaka, I remember, you know, drinking the alcohol, but not getting the desired effect. It was just I was so shocked and so numb. The plan his friends laid out went like this. The four cops would dress up as FBI agents and conduct a fake raid on the home. It wasn't like the book he was going to call the police. He'd have to explain how a million dollars came to be sitting in a safe.
起初我以为这是个玩笑。我以为这非常、非常滑稽。但随着谈话的继续，他开始画出目标房屋的图纸，以及我们将如何接近这所房子。我记得，尚卡尔，我记得，你知道，喝着酒，但并没有达到预期的效果。我只是感到非常震惊和麻木。他的朋友们制定的计划是这样的。四名警察将打扮成联邦调查局特工，对这所房子进行突击搜查。那个赌徒不可能报警。他得解释这一百万美元是怎么出现在保险箱里的。
Unspoken was the idea that even though breaking into the book he's house was obviously illegal, it could also be the right thing to do. The money they'd be stealing was from a crook. In a way, they'd be writing a wrong. Darwin's friends told him the first step was to stake out the house. Then, on the day of the raid, they'd call 911 and report there was an officer in trouble far away from the house. And that would distract all the local units to that location.
大家心照不宣的是，尽管闯入赌徒的家显然是非法的，但这也可能是正确的事情。他们要偷的钱来自一个骗子。在某种程度上，他们是在纠正错误。达尔文的朋友告诉他，第一步是监视这所房子。然后，在突击搜查的那天，他们会拨打911，报告说有一名警察在离房子很远的地方遇到了麻烦。这将分散所有当地警力的注意力，让他们前往那个地点。
Free and clear of any interruptions, the cops would break in, tie up the bookie, spray him with mace, and force him to reveal the code to the safe. And if he refused or in any way didn't allow us to get the money out, then we would take any means necessary up and to including death. Wow, so they actually talked about killing the guy if he didn't cooperate. Yes, absolutely.
在没有任何干扰的情况下，警察们会闯入，绑住赌徒，向他喷射催泪瓦斯，并强迫他说出保险箱的密码。如果他拒绝或以任何方式不允许我们拿走钱，那么我们将采取任何必要手段，包括杀人。哇，所以他们真的谈到了如果他不配合就杀掉他。是的，绝对是。
Darwin felt a battle start to rage inside his brain. The scheme felt wrong, but he also felt a deep loyalty to these men. These are the people that I work with every day. I put my life in their hands and hopefully they put their lives in my hands. These were people that I looked up to for, you know, aspiration and what kind of cop I wanted to be with the Detroit Police Department. After they laid out the plan, Darwin's friends looked at him and asked him a question that would shape the rest of his life. Are you in or are you out?
达尔文感到大脑里开始爆发一场战斗。这个计划感觉是错的，但他对这些人也有一种深厚的忠诚感。这些人是我每天一起工作的人。我把生命交到他们手中，希望他们也把生命交到我手中。这些人是我一直仰望的对象，关于我想成为什么样的警察，我想加入什么样的底特律警察局。在他们制定完计划后，达尔文的朋友们看着他，问了他一个将影响他余生的问题：你加入还是退出？
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. At Northwestern University's Kellogg School of Management, psychologist Adam Wates has long been fascinated by the kind of dilemma Darwin Roshe experienced at that bar in Detroit. What happens in the mind when someone has to make a choice between two competing ethical priorities? My first interest in the topic of whistle blowing came from hearing about a news story in Chicago's, terrible story, something about someone getting shot.
你正在收听《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。在西北大学凯洛格管理学院，心理学家亚当·韦茨长期以来一直对达尔文·罗谢尔在底特律那家酒吧经历的那种困境很感兴趣。当一个人必须在两个相互竞争的道德优先事项之间做出选择时，大脑中会发生什么？我对举报话题的最初兴趣来自于听到芝加哥的一个新闻故事，一个可怕的故事，关于有人被枪杀。
And as they were dying, the police actually approached the person who got shot and as they were dying, the police actually approached the person who got shot and said, can you help us? Do you know who did this? And the person essentially said something along the lines of, I know who did this, but I'll never tell you. I know who did this, but I'll never tell you. Adam was struck by the story.
当他们垂死时，警察实际上走近了那个被枪杀的人，当他们垂死时，警察实际上走近了那个被枪杀的人并说，你能帮帮我们吗？你知道是谁干的吗？那个人基本上说了类似这样的话：我知道是谁干的，但我永远不会告诉你。我知道是谁干的，但我永远不会告诉你。亚当被这个故事震撼了。
Here was a man who was dying and he was trying to protect the person who'd shot him. Out of kind of a code of silence, a code of don't snitch. And I remember talking to someone who was leading an anti-gun violence organization and this person had worked with communities as well as the police and this person who I relayed the story to said, well, you know, this is very interesting because there's a similar code of silence within police departments as well. As a psychologist, Adam asked himself what the connection could be. Why would the victims of crimes and the people trying to catch the perpetrators of crimes
这是一个垂死的人，他试图保护那个开枪打他的人。出于一种沉默法则，一种“不要告密”的法则。我记得曾与一位领导反枪支暴力组织的人交谈过，这个人曾与社区以及警察合作，我向他转述了这个故事，他说，嗯，你知道，这非常有趣，因为警察部门内部也存在类似的沉默法则。作为一名心理学家，亚当问自己这之间有什么联系。为什么犯罪的受害者和试图抓住罪犯的人
follow the same code? There seemed to be something about a code of loyalty, and so I started talking about that with Leon Young and James Dungan, and we said, well, you know, this could be something interesting to study from a psychological perspective. Adam and his colleagues decided a good place to start their analysis was in the field of what's called moral foundations theory. There are these five or six kind of basic moral intuitions or moral foundations or moral modules that people use intuitively to determine whether something was right and wrong. When we ask ourselves what's right and wrong, we usually don't realize that beneath
会遵循同样的法则？这似乎与忠诚法则有关，所以我开始与莱昂·杨和詹姆斯·邓根讨论这个问题，我们说，嗯，你知道，这可能是一个从心理学角度研究的有趣课题。亚当和他的同事决定，分析的一个好起点是所谓的“道德基础理论”。有五六种基本的道德直觉、道德基础或道德模块，人们直觉地用它们来判断某事是对是错。当我们问自己什么是对什么是错时，我们通常没有意识到，在
the surface of our reasoning, we're actually drawing on a deeper set of moral feelings. These feelings form the foundations of our moral reasoning. Moral Foundation's theory was first put forward by the psychologist Jonathan Height and Jesse Graham, who hypothesized that people don't realize they are unconsciously drawing on different moral foundations. This in turn is a central reason why people are bewildered when others reach different moral conclusions. The people who thought Edward Snowden was a trader may have felt that those who called Edward Snowden a hero needed to have their heads examined and vice versa. What was so interesting to us was that two of those foundations can very easily come into
我们推理的表面之下，我们实际上是在利用一套更深层的道德情感。这些情感构成了我们道德推理的基础。道德基础理论最早由心理学家乔纳森·海特和杰西·格雷厄姆提出，他们假设人们没有意识到自己在无意识地利用不同的道德基础。这反过来也是为什么当其他人得出不同的道德结论时，人们会感到困惑的核心原因。那些认为爱德华·斯诺登是叛徒的人，可能觉得那些称爱德华·斯诺登为英雄的人需要检查一下脑袋，反之亦然。对我们来说，最有趣的是，其中两个基础很容易发生
conflict with each other. Cultures around the world understand that one way to be a good person is to stand by those who stand with you. We defend our families, communities and nations, and we expect our families, communities and nations to defend us even when the going gets tough. Flicking out doesn't just make you a coward, it makes you unreliable, this loyal, a bad person. Simultaneously, however, many of us also intuitively feel that being a good person means standing up for fairness and justice. Stealing from someone is unjust.
冲突。世界各地的文化都理解，做一个好人的方式之一就是支持那些支持你的人。我们捍卫我们的家庭、社区和国家，我们也期望我们的家庭、社区和国家捍卫我们，即使在困难时期也是如此。告密不仅让你成为懦夫，还让你变得不可靠、不忠诚，是一个坏人。然而，与此同时，我们许多人也直觉地感到，做一个好人意味着坚持公平和正义。偷窃别人的东西是不公正的。
Hearding someone is unfair. One place, these two moral foundations come into conflict. It just so happens that these kind of core intuitions, that is the desire for loyalty, and simultaneously the desire for justice, really come into conflict with each other when people are put in situations where they have to decide whether to blow the whistle or not. When we think about Darwin Rocher, it's easy to think his choice was either to be loyal to his colleagues or to do the right thing. But this is a mistake. The moral foundation of justice is not superior to the moral foundation of loyalty. It's just that different situations can make
伤害别人是不公平的。这两个道德基础发生冲突的一个地方。恰好，当人们处于必须决定是否举报的境地时，这种核心直觉，即对忠诚的渴望和对正义的渴望，确实会发生冲突。当我们想到达尔文·罗谢尔时，很容易认为他的选择要么是忠于同事，要么是做正确的事。但这是一个错误。正义的道德基础并不优于忠诚的道德基础。只是不同的情况会使
different people lean in one direction or the other. We all face balancing acts between honesty and loyalty. Let's say you see a colleague stealing toilet paper from the office supply closet. Do you report it? What if they were embezzling money from the company? Or let's say you have a very kind neighbor who brings you soup when you're sick, but this person also posts fake news on social media. Do you call him out? What if you see him abusing a dog? How does the gravity of the act change the equation? It's not clear what the right thing is, and this is where we landed in our hypothesizing that many people and many cultures feel like the most right thing you can do is be a loyal citizen to your community,
不同的人向一个方向或另一个方向倾斜。我们都面临着诚实与忠诚之间的平衡。假设你看到一个同事从办公用品柜里偷卫生纸。你会举报吗？如果他们挪用公司资金呢？或者假设你有一个非常善良的邻居，在你生病时给你送汤，但这个人也在社交媒体上发布假新闻。你会揭穿他吗？如果你看到他虐待狗呢？行为的严重性如何改变等式？什么是正确的事情并不清楚，这就是我们假设的落脚点：许多人和许多文化觉得你能做的最正确的事情就是成为你社区的忠诚公民，
whatever that is, whether that's a police department, whether that's a neighborhood, whether that's a place where you work, that is the ultimate immorality is being loyal. That is the ultimate immorality is being loyal. On the other hand, you have this competing moral intuition where you want to do what's just and what's fair and what prevents the greatest amount of harm to others more broadly. And so if you look at it one way whistle blowing is the most moral thing you can do, but if you look at it another way, it feels like the ultimate betrayal. Adam and his colleagues have shown that our inner moral calculations can be tipped in one direction
无论那是什么，无论是警察部门、社区还是你工作的地方，终极的不道德就是不忠诚。终极的不道德就是不忠诚。另一方面，你有这种相互竞争的道德直觉，你想做公正和公平的事情，防止对他人的伤害最大化。所以如果你从一个角度看，举报是你所能做的最道德的事情，但如果你从另一个角度看，它感觉像是终极背叛。亚当和他的同事们已经证明，我们内心的道德计算可以向一个方向
or another. In one study, they recruited two groups of volunteers. The first was asked to write an essay on the importance of fairness and honesty. The other was asked to write about the value of loyalty. All the volunteers were then told to evaluate the work of previous participants in the study. In reality, however, there were no previous participants and the research team was asking the volunteers to evaluate poorly done work that they themselves had fabricated. The researchers asked the volunteers to blow the whistle about poorly done work.
或另一个方向倾斜。在一项研究中，他们招募了两组志愿者。第一组被要求写一篇关于公平和诚实重要性的文章。另一组被要求写关于忠诚价值的文章。然后，所有志愿者都被告知要评估研究中先前参与者的工作。然而实际上，并没有先前的参与者，研究小组要求志愿者评估他们自己编造的糟糕工作。研究人员要求志愿者举报糟糕的工作。
Here's research at James Dungan from the University of Chicago. And the question for the participants in our task was, would they report this shoddy work or not? The researchers told the volunteers that if they reported shoddy work, the previous participant would be banned from working on any future studies. What we see is that whistle blowing behavior was affected by the essay prompt that they wrote. So people writing about the importance of fairness, who are made to remind themselves of how important it is to be fair,
这是来自芝加哥大学的研究员詹姆斯·邓根。我们任务中参与者的问题是，他们是否会举报这种粗制滥造的工作？研究人员告诉志愿者，如果他们举报粗制滥造的工作，先前的参与者将被禁止参加任何未来的研究。我们看到，举报行为受到了他们所写的文章提示的影响。所以，写关于公平重要性的人，那些被迫提醒自己公平有多重要的人，
were more likely to report the participants' shoddy work, people who were focused on loyalty, were less likely to report the participant. What this shows is that our internal moral compass is not static. It's also not just about what happens inside our own minds. Social factors in the context can alter how we feel about profoundly important moral decisions. So when some of us think Edward Snowden is a hero and some of us think he's a villain,
更有可能举报参与者的粗制滥造工作；而那些关注忠诚的人，则不太可能举报参与者。这表明我们的内在道德指南针不是静态的。它也不仅仅是关于我们自己头脑中发生的事情。社会因素和环境可以改变我们对极其重要的道德决策的感受。所以，当一些人认为爱德华·斯诺登是英雄，而另一些人认为他是恶棍时，
it may be useful to ask how different social norms and social ties are shaping those conclusions. At a larger level, the cultures in which we find ourselves can also play a powerful role in nudging us to prioritize honesty or loyalty. Researchers have found that different cultures prioritize different moral foundations, perhaps because of their unique historical circumstances. Here's Adam on that topic. Worked by Michelle Gelfand and others had suggested that when countries experience crises, whether due to war or famine or natural disaster, they tighten up.
询问不同的社会规范和社会关系如何塑造这些结论可能是有用的。在更大的层面上，我们所处的文化也可以在促使我们优先考虑诚实或忠诚方面发挥强大的作用。研究人员发现，不同的文化优先考虑不同的道德基础，这可能是因为它们独特的历史环境。亚当谈到了这个话题。米歇尔·格尔凡德等人的工作表明，当国家经历危机时，无论是由于战争、饥荒还是自然灾害，它们都会收紧。
And to the extent that tightening up or promoting sort of tighter social norms is going to weaken whistle blowing, I think in the aftermath of crises, people are going to be less likely to break with their fellow country people. I'm wondering if you or anyone else has done research looking at organizations that believe they are doing the right thing. So police departments or the army or medical workers. You have a sense that partly what motivates you to join this profession is a sense of mission, a sense of duty, a sense of responsibility to hire things.
在某种程度上，收紧或促进更严格的社会规范会削弱举报行为，我认为在危机之后，人们不太可能与同胞决裂。我想知道你或其他任何人是否做过研究，观察那些认为自己在做正确事情的组织。比如警察部门、军队或医务工作者。你有一种感觉，部分激励你加入这个职业的是使命感、责任感、对更高事物的责任感。
And I'm wondering if there's been any research looking at the likelihood of whistle blowing in those contexts, partly because I'm wondering if the conflict in some ways becomes more acute. So in other words, if I'm working for, let's say, doctors without borders. And I think that I'm working for a humanitarian organization that's doing really wonderful things. Now if I blow the whistle, I'm not just potentially hurting the organization or hurting the people within the organization. I'm hurting all the people that the organization could have helped.
我想知道是否有人研究过这些环境下的举报可能性，部分是因为我想知道这种冲突在某些方面是否变得更加尖锐。换句话说，如果我为“无国界医生”工作。我认为我为一个正在做非常美妙事情的人道主义组织工作。现在如果我举报，我不仅可能伤害组织或组织内的人。我还在伤害组织本可以帮助的所有人。
And now that makes the moral dilemma, at least the way I'm seeing it, even more acute. Well, you know, you gave me just the perfect testable hypothesis. I want to run out and do this research tomorrow. And I think you're really onto something where to the extent to which you believe that your organization has a bigger social mission, and this can be true of police departments, the military, again, other examples of user,
现在这使得道德困境，至少在我看来，变得更加尖锐。嗯，你知道，你给了我一个完美的、可测试的假设。我明天就想跑去进行这项研究。我认为你真的发现了什么，在某种程度上，你相信你的组织有更大的社会使命，这对于警察部门、军队来说都是如此，其他例子还有，
Boy Scouts of America, or the Catholic Church, and indeed these are mission-driven organizations, the conflict might be lessened for you because you might say, well, the reason why I'm not gonna report wrongdoing is that that would weaken our organization. And so really, what the greater good is for me is that our organization thrives, so we can
美国童子军或天主教会，确实这些是使命驱动的组织，冲突对你来说可能会减轻，因为你可能会说，嗯，我不举报不当行为的原因是那会削弱我们的组织。所以真的，对我来说更大的利益是我们的组织蓬勃发展，这样我们才能
do the good work that we do. And so, you know, that might explain why within those organizations, you know, you're saying that your purpose is partially socially driven. And that then gives you license to engage in potentially less ethical behavior. It's a phenomenon called moral licensing, the idea developed by a psychologist Benoit Mounin and Dale Miller, where if you think of yourself as having a certain level of morality,
做我们所做的善事。所以，你知道，这可能解释了为什么在这些组织内部，你说你的目的是部分社会驱动的。这给了你从事潜在的不道德行为的许可。这是一种被称为“道德许可”的现象，由心理学家贝努瓦·穆宁和戴尔·米勒发展而来，即如果你认为自己具有某种程度的道德，
then it licenses you to be less moral on other dimensions. And so that might also occur in the whistle blowing context. I mean, in some ways, the idea is that if you're basically already putting money in your moral piggy bank by doing a good thing, by being part of a mission driven organization or a humanitarian organization, it now becomes a little easier to take money out of that piggy bank
那么它就许可你在其他维度上不那么道德。所以这在举报背景下也可能发生。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这个想法是，如果你通过做一件好事，通过成为使命驱动组织或人道主义组织的一部分，已经在你的道德存钱罐里存了钱，那么当你被要求这样做时，从存钱罐里取钱就变得容易了一些，
when you're called upon to do so because you say, well, my piggy bank is already pretty full with all of these moral coins. Absolutely. You're still morally wealthy, even if you take more coins out. Adam can think of a moment in his own life when he was torn between the moral impulse of loyalty and the moral impulse of honesty. He was a senior in high school, and his brother David was a sophomore, and they had gone to a classic high school party.
因为你说，嗯，我的存钱罐里已经装满了这些道德硬币。绝对是。即使你取出更多的硬币，你仍然在道德上很富有。亚当能想到他自己生活中一个在忠诚的道德冲动和诚实的道德冲动之间挣扎的时刻。他当时是高三学生，他的弟弟大卫是高二学生，他们去参加了一个典型的高中派对。
Think cheap plastic cups filled with bad beer. At some point in the night, one of the party goes to a picture of the scene, and the next week, the photograph started making its way around the school. And in our public school system, you know, there's nothing you can do to a student who was drinking alcohol off campus, but there was some rule in place that if you're an athlete, a high school athlete, you could be suspended if you're found, consume the alcohol even if it was outside of school grounds. Adam was on the basketball team. David did cross-country. They were going to be called in for questioning.
想想装满劣质啤酒的廉价塑料杯。在晚上的某个时候，派对参与者之一拍了一张现场照片，接下来的一周，这张照片开始在学校流传。在我们的公立学校系统中，你知道，你不能对在校外喝酒的学生做任何事，但有一条规则是，如果你是一名运动员，一名高中运动员，如果你被发现饮酒，即使是在校外，也可能被停赛。亚当是篮球队的。大卫参加越野赛。他们将被传唤接受询问。
Adam had a choice. Lie and protect his brother and his teammates, or tell the truth, and get everyone in trouble. Of course, Adam was not the only one confronting this choice. Everyone who knew they were going to get called in for questioning had this decision to make. Do we all, you know, basically lie and say, I wasn't drinking at the party or what you see in my cup is apple juice and not beer. You know, do we maintain that code of silence or do we tell the truth? Before Adam or David got called into the office, they run the food and came up with the
亚当面临一个选择。撒谎并保护他的弟弟和队友，或者说实话，让每个人都陷入麻烦。当然，亚当并不是唯一面临这个选择的人。每个知道自己将被传唤接受询问的人都必须做出这个决定。我们是否都，你知道，基本上撒谎说，我没有在派对上喝酒，或者你在我杯子里看到的是苹果汁而不是啤酒。你知道，我们是维持那种沉默法则，还是说实话？在亚当或大卫被叫进办公室之前，他们跑去吃东西，并想出了
plan. Let's just say we were drinking apple juice if anyone asks. Slowly each of his teammates was brought in. Eventually, it was Adam's turn. And I was asked, was I drinking at the party? And I said I was not. Adam chose the moral foundation of loyalty over the moral foundation of justice, of honesty.
计划。如果有人问，我们就说我们在喝苹果汁。慢慢地，他的每个队友都被带进去了。最终，轮到亚当了。我被问到，我在派对上喝酒了吗？我说我没有。亚当选择了忠诚的道德基础，而不是正义和诚实的道德基础。
But then, in an almost comical demonstration of what happens when moral foundations come into conflict with each other, he immediately felt torn about his decision. I walked out of that office, and I just felt bad. It did not feel good to tell a lie. After walking about 50 feet, I turned around and I recanted my statement. This is the thing about our moral foundations.
但随后，在一个几乎滑稽的道德基础相互冲突的演示中，他立即对自己做出的决定感到纠结。我走出办公室，感觉很糟糕。撒谎的感觉并不好。走了大约50英尺后，我转过身，撤回了我的陈述。这就是我们道德基础的问题。
We don't notice them most of the time because they're hidden beneath the surface. Yet, when we ignore them, we experience what Adam calls moral stress. Which is the stress brought on by having to stretch the truth or do something that feels immoral. And that's what I felt. It was, you know, momentarily debilitating. It was very stressful to know that I had lied. And not only that, but yeah, I could get away with it,
我们大多数时候没有注意到它们，因为它们隐藏在表面之下。然而，当我们忽视它们时，我们就会经历亚当所说的“道德压力”。也就是因为不得不歪曲事实或做一些感觉不道德的事情而带来的压力。这就是我的感受。这，你知道，暂时让人虚弱。知道自己撒谎了，压力很大。不仅如此，是的，我可以逃脱惩罚，
but I think plenty of people in the school knew the actual story, and that was gonna be embarrassing. When we come back, moral stress in a situation with the highest of stakes. We return to that bar in Detroit and Darwin-Rose is dilemma. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The events that change our lives don't always look monumental from the outside. To a stranger who might have seen Darwin
但我认为学校里很多人都知道真实的故事，那会很尴尬。当我们回来时，在赌注最高的情况下，道德压力。我们回到底特律的那家酒吧，回到达尔文·罗谢尔的困境。你正在收听《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。改变我们生活的事件从外部看并不总是显得意义重大。对于一个可能看到达尔文
and his colleagues in that dive bar, they probably look like four friends drinking beer, talking about life. But as his fellow police officers asked him to help them carry out a crime, break into a house and steal a million dollars, Darwin felt his head spin. It was just one of those things that, regardless, if I say yes or no, now, you know, I still have to have a relationship with these officers. I got to get in the scout car with them two days from now. As he made his way home, Darwin thought about the decision he had to make. No answer he
和他的同事在那家小酒吧里的陌生人来说，他们看起来可能就像四个喝着啤酒、谈论生活的朋友。但当他的警察同事要求他帮助他们实施犯罪、闯入一所房子并偷走一百万美元时，达尔文感到头晕目眩。这只是那种无论我说是还是否，现在，你知道，我仍然必须与这些警察保持关系的事情之一。两天后我还得和他们一起坐上巡逻车。在回家的路上，达尔文思考着他必须做出的决定。没有一个答案他
landed on felt good. If you went along with the plan, he'd be helping perpetrate an injustice. The kind of injustice he had sworn an oath to prevent. But if he turned on his buddies, turned them in, Darwin knew he would feel like he had betrayed them. If he got them convicted, he would feel responsible for taking their lives away, for creating that empty chair at the dinner table that their wives, girlfriends, and kids would have to look at each night. When he got home, Darwin was distraught. He called someone he trusted and asked her to come over. And so I told her what happened and she said, well, you know, what are you going to do? You know, she kind of advised me, well, just don't say anything. I said, well, no, I can't do that.
觉得好受。如果你同意这个计划，你就是在帮助实施不公正。那种他发誓要防止的不公正。但如果他背叛了他的伙伴，把他们举报了，达尔文知道他会觉得背叛了他们。如果他让他们被定罪，他会觉得有责任夺走他们的生命，在餐桌上制造出他们的妻子、女朋友和孩子每晚都必须面对的空椅子。回到家后，达尔文心烦意乱。他给一个他信任的人打了电话，让她过来。所以我告诉了她发生的事情，她说，嗯，你知道，你打算怎么做？你知道，她建议我，嗯，什么都别说。我说，嗯，不，我不能那样做。
Because I have to put myself in the situation of that person in that house and allowing something bad to happen to him for something that I had prior knowledge of. It just couldn't resonate with me. I just could not wrap my head around doing that. As they talked, it became clear to Darwin which moral choice felt better to him and which one felt worse. As much as loyalty to his friends mattered, as much as it broke his heart to turn away
因为我必须把自己放在那所房子里那个人的处境中，如果我明知会发生坏事却允许它发生。这对我来说根本说不通。我无法接受那样做。当他们交谈时，达尔文清楚地知道哪种道德选择对他来说感觉更好，哪种感觉更糟。尽管对朋友的忠诚很重要，尽管背离他们让他心碎，
from them, he knew he could not take part in the crime. And he could not say idly by as the book he was robbed and maybe killed. I reached out to the chief of police. The only person I know that, you know, that I felt that I could have trusted with this information, told them what had happened, told them what I knew, and he said, okay, well, stand by the phone, someone will be calling you. A short while later, Darwin got a call from the FBI. They arranged to meet at a park the next day.
但他知道他不能参与犯罪。他不能袖手旁观，看着赌徒被抢劫甚至可能被杀。我联系了警察局长。我唯一认识的、你知道，我觉得我可以信任他提供这些信息的人，告诉了他发生的事情，告诉了他我知道的一切，他说，好的，好吧，守着电话，会有人给你打电话的。不久之后，达尔文接到了联邦调查局的电话。他们安排第二天在公园见面。
They brought me in and they kind of said, okay, well walk us through what happened. With a not anistamok, Darwin told them everything. When he was done, they gave him a choice. They pretty much directly said, hey, do you want to participate in helping catching these guys? Or do you just want wanna give us the information and go about your life? Darwin felt that if he had made the choice to come down on the side of justice, he had to take the plunge. If he didn't, and his fellow officer's God of Scott free,
他们把我带进去，他们说，好的，好吧，带我们走一遍发生了什么。达尔文如实告诉了他们一切。当他完成后，他们给了他一个选择。他们非常直接地说，嘿，你想参与帮助抓住这些人吗？还是你只想给我们信息，然后继续你的生活？达尔文觉得，如果他做出了站在正义一边的选择，他就必须一头扎进去。如果他不这样做，而他的警察同事逍遥法外，
showing up at work as usual, he would have to quit. If I don't participate in this, if I don't see it through, if I don't get this this, if I don't see it through, if I don't get this to a conviction, they may walk. They may be found not guilty. So all my dreams and aspirations are gone. Everything I went to college for, everything I believed in, serving the community, serving the citizens of Detroit, that is done. If they don't go to jail. And at this point, I had to go where the odds are more favorable for me and my career,
如果像往常一样去上班，他就必须辞职。如果我不参与这件事，如果我不坚持到底，如果我不能把这件事办成，如果我不能把它定罪，他们可能会逃脱惩罚。他们可能会被判无罪。那么我所有的梦想和抱负都破灭了。我上大学所学的一切，我所信仰的一切，服务社区，服务底特律市民，这一切都完了。如果他们不坐牢的话。在这一点上，我必须选择对我个人和职业生涯更有利的方向，
my name, my family, my belief systems. And I said, well, I'm here to help. So the thing that I just want to spend a moment talking about is that I feel like for many people, this would have been a difficult decision. You know, because again, you're not just reporting on something that you saw happen, you're reporting on people who you work with, people who are your friends, people who know your kid, you know, people who looked out for you, people who have, you know, you look up to. I would think for most people, they would be at least a moment of emotional conflict where you're deciding what the right thing is to do. Emotional conflict is an understatement.
我的名声，我的家庭，我的信仰体系。我说，好吧，我是来帮忙的。所以我想花点时间谈谈的是，我觉得对很多人来说，这会是一个艰难的决定。因为再说一次，你不仅仅是在报道你看到的事情，你是在报道和你一起工作的人，你的朋友，认识你孩子的人，照顾过你的人，你敬仰的人。我想对大多数人来说，在决定什么是正确的事情时，至少会有一瞬间的情感冲突。情感冲突这个词都说轻了。
This was gut-wrenching. It was very painful to make that decision. And you know, I love these guys. I mean, we really shared a lot of time together. It was very emotionally draining and very traumatic for me to go through that. Those days after that initial contact with them and subsequent contact with the FBI and life. Darwin kept going to work each day except now he was consumed with anxiety. I had to, you know, actually work with the authorities and continue my day-to-day activities as nothing's changed because if anything if I change anything a day
这真是令人揪心。做出那个决定非常痛苦。你知道，我爱这些家伙。我的意思是，我们确实在一起度过了很多时光。经历这些对我来说在情感上非常耗费精力，也非常痛苦。在与他们最初接触以及随后与联邦调查局接触后的那些日子里，生活还在继续。达尔文每天照常上班，只是现在他被焦虑所吞噬。我不得不，你知道，实际上与当局合作，并继续我的日常活动，好像什么都没变，因为如果我改变了任何一天
off or left work early or anything like that, it could have possibly alerted them that something is a foot. So on the outside, I appeared normal, but on the inside, I was really like shattered in pieces and conflicted. Instead of blurring out that he'd betrayed them, that the FBI was following their every move, Darwin met up with his colleagues. He told them he was in. Fully in.
请假或早退或类似的事情，都可能引起他们的警觉，让他们觉得有什么不对劲。所以从外表上看，我表现得很正常，但内心深处，我真的像碎了一样，充满矛盾。达尔文没有脱口而出他背叛了他们，没有说联邦调查局正在跟踪他们的一举一动，而是去见了同事。他告诉他们他加入了。完全加入了。
They would do drive-bys of the house, trying to figure out the best way to get in. They started gathering supplies and weapons. Throughout all of this, Darwin either wore a wire or wrote extensive notes that he'd pass along to the FBI. Now, besides the conflict he felt as a whistleblower, Darwin realized how terrifying it was to be an informant. I was in an altered state. I was in one of those where I had to really step outside myself who I was and kind of get into almost a role play where I had to, you know, pretend that I was an active participant. I had to pretend that I was, you know, enthusiastic about conducting this criminal activity, you know, while at the same time, I always paranoid,
他们会开车绕着房子转，试图找出进入的最佳方式。他们开始收集补给品和武器。在这一切过程中，达尔文要么戴着窃听器，要么写下详细的笔记交给联邦调查局。现在，除了作为举报人感到的冲突外，达尔文意识到作为线人是多么可怕。我处于一种改变的状态。我处于那种必须真正跳出自我，跳出我是谁的状态，有点像角色扮演，我必须，你知道，假装我是一个积极的参与者。我必须假装我，你知道，对进行这种犯罪活动很热心，你知道，与此同时，我总是很偏执，
always emotionally on edge. He became hyper-vigilant and suffered frequent panic attacks. And then, one cold afternoon, Darwin had just come off a lunch break when a coworker showed him the Detroit Free Press. Plastered across the front page with this headline, cops planned heist. Three Detroit police officers charged with blood. And so that's how I found out that they actually made their rest earlier that morning. Heist, three Detroit police officers charged with blood. And so that's how I found out that they actually made their rest earlier that morning. It's typical for the FBI to withhold information from informants about the progress of an
总是情绪紧张。他变得过度警觉，并经常遭受恐慌发作。然后，在一个寒冷的下午，达尔文刚吃完午饭，一位同事给他看了《底特律自由报》。头版头条赫然写着：警察策划抢劫。三名底特律警察被控抢劫。这就是我发现他们那天早上早些时候实施逮捕的方式。抢劫，三名底特律警察被控抢劫。这就是我发现他们那天早上早些时候实施逮捕的方式。联邦调查局通常会对线人隐瞒调查进展的信息，
investigation. They don't want informants to get cold feet and warn the group they've been investigating. Darwin knew this and he tried to prepare himself for the moment it all came out. It was still a shock, but nothing compared to what came in the weeks and months that followed. That's because the tension between loyalty and honesty
他们不想让线人临阵退缩，去警告他们正在调查的团伙。达尔文知道这一点，他试图为这一切曝光的时刻做好准备。这仍然是一个冲击，但与随后的几周和几个月里发生的事情相比，根本不算什么。这是因为忠诚与诚实之间的紧张关系
was not just a question to be resolved in Darwin's heart. His community was weighing the very same questions. Was Darwin Rocher a hero or a traitor? I would get calls. We're going to kill you. You're not going to make it the trial. And the calls were frequent throughout the day or night. I actually had a security detail assigned to my home, just based upon those threats. After a while, the death threats, they became so prevalent, it was just like, just do it.
不仅仅是达尔文内心需要解决的问题。他的社区也在权衡同样的问题。达尔文·罗彻是英雄还是叛徒？我会接到电话。我们要杀了你。你活不到审判那天。这些电话在白天或晚上频繁打来。我甚至因为这些威胁而给家里安排了安保人员。过了一段时间，死亡威胁变得如此普遍，感觉就像是，来吧，动手吧。
I stopped calling, just do it. And one thing I always said, I would not want to be shot in a face or the head, so I could have an open casket funeral. And that was my only thing and so it was very, it was very trying, very traumatic. The pressure slowly mounted on everyone in Darwin's life. At one point, the house where his ex-girlfriend and 12-year-old daughter lived was firebombed. Thankfully, Darwin's ex and daughter came away from the incident physically unharmed. But knowing that his decision to blow the whistle had put his child in jeopardy,
我不再接电话了，动手吧。我一直说的一件事是，我不想脸部或头部中弹，这样我还能举行开棺葬礼。这是我唯一的要求，所以这非常折磨人，非常痛苦。达尔文生活中的每个人都承受着越来越大的压力。有一次，他前女友和12岁女儿住的房子被纵火了。谢天谢地，达尔文的前女友和女儿在事件中没有受到身体伤害。但知道他举报的决定让他的孩子陷入了危险，
pushed Darwin over the edge. I had reached my emotional bottom. I was isolated. I don't have the ability to go to the store without worrying if someone's going to come up on me and take my life away. Or answer the phone without fear in that someone's going to put me in that emotional state of fear and discomfort.
把达尔文推向了崩溃的边缘。我达到了情感的最低谷。我被孤立了。我没有能力去商店，而不担心是否有人会冲上来夺走我的生命。或者在接电话时，不担心有人会让我陷入那种恐惧和不安的情绪状态。
Or the ability just to have friends over and just to say hi because if someone's trying to kill you or someone has threatened to kill you, it's not a lot of people that want to be around. Darwin was transferred to desk duty. While many of his colleagues supported him and held him up as a model of good policing, others were angry about his decision. This is a common experience for many whistleblowers. The people for whom the moral foundation of honesty and justice is paramount will view your actions in one way. The people for whom loyalty is a core moral foundation will see the same actions very differently. As a trial grew nearer, Darwin felt like he was in a race. A race for his life.
或者没有能力邀请朋友过来打个招呼，因为如果有人想杀你，或者有人威胁要杀你，没有多少人愿意待在你身边。达尔文被调到了文职岗位。虽然他的许多同事支持他，并把他视为良好警务的典范，但其他人对他的决定感到愤怒。这对许多举报人来说是一种常见的经历。那些将诚实和正义的道德基础视为至高无上的人会以一种方式看待你的行为。那些将忠诚视为核心道德基础的人会以非常不同的方式看待同样的行为。随着审判临近，达尔文感觉自己像是在赛跑。一场为生命而战的赛跑。
We always talk about, you know, crossing the finish line, but very suddenly we talk about the work that goes after you crossed the finish line. And in this situation, you know, the hard work was just to survive, emotionally survive this and hopefully stand alive to participate in trial and testify against the actions that they did. And so I just got up every day and treated each day as it was my last. And that was the mindset I had to have in order just to kind of, you know, stay sane for lack of a better word. Darwin made it to the trial of life.
我们总是谈论，你知道，冲过终点线，但很少谈论冲过终点线之后的工作。在这种情况下，你知道，艰苦的工作只是为了生存，在情感上熬过这一切，并希望活着参加审判，对他们的行为作证。所以我每天起床，把每一天都当作最后一天来过。为了保持理智，我必须有这种心态，用一个更好的词来说。
He testified against his former friends in court and told the truth about what he'd heard and witnessed. The three men were found guilty, although the conviction of one officer was overturned on appeal. All served some prison time. Given that the events in this story happened decades ago, and the other cops either served their time, or in one case had his conviction over turn, we have chosen not to name them in this story.
他在法庭上指证了以前的朋友，并说出了他所听到和看到的事实。这三个人被判有罪，尽管其中一名警官的定罪在上诉中被推翻。所有人都服了一些刑期。鉴于这个故事中的事件发生在几十年前，而其他警察要么服完了刑，要么在一种情况下定罪被推翻，我们选择不在这个故事中提及他们的名字。
After the trial, Darwin's life moved on. The threats subsided. He was taken off desk duty and went back to patrolling the streets of Detroit. He retired in early 2022 as a lieutenant. There are people who still disagree with the choice he made. He still occasionally hears people refer to him as a snitch. But Darwin says he'd make the same decision again if he had to, even with all the pain it caused. I mean, if you don't stand out for what is right and what is just and your own moral beliefs,
审判结束后，达尔文的生活继续前行。威胁平息了。他被调离了文职岗位，回到了底特律街头巡逻。他于2022年初以中尉身份退休。仍然有人不同意他所做的选择。他偶尔还会听到有人称他为告密者。但达尔文说，如果必须的话，他还是会做出同样的决定，即使这带来了所有的痛苦。我的意思是，如果你不为正确和正义的事情以及你自己的道德信仰挺身而出，
then how do we change society? We have a society right now that is so willing to kind of duck into the shadows and hope that someone else will handle it. And that problem causes a lot of issues in our lives. When we're forced to choose between loyalty and honesty, it can feel agonizing. Yet, psychologist Adam Wates says there is a way to reduce the agony, at least in an organizational context. The way to do that is by reframing the underlying tension between loyalty and honesty.
那么我们如何改变社会？我们现在所处的社会非常愿意躲进阴影里，希望别人来处理。这个问题在我们的生活中造成了很多麻烦。当我们被迫在忠诚和诚实之间做出选择时，可能会感到痛苦。然而，心理学家亚当·韦茨说，有一种方法可以减轻这种痛苦，至少在组织背景下是这样。方法就是重新构建忠诚与诚实之间潜在的紧张关系。
When we talk about how to overcome the tension between while doing the just thing versus being loyal to my group, the answer we don't try to put forth is, well, you should just forget about loyalty. I mean, first of all, it's impossible. Loyalty is sort of baked in all of us. It's part of human nature to want to be loyal. But loyalty is something that I think can be reframed as loyalty to your fellow human
当我们谈论如何克服做正确的事与对团队忠诚之间的紧张关系时，我们不想提出的答案是，好吧，你应该忘记忠诚。我的意思是，首先，这不可能。忠诚在某种程度上植根于我们所有人。想要忠诚是人性的一部分。但我认为忠诚可以被重新定义为对你的人类同胞的忠诚，
beings, or loyalty to the greater good, or loyalty to society. And so there's a way to, I think, blow the whistle, which might be calling out someone in your circle, or your organization for wrongdoing, while still feeling a sense of loyalty. For some people, the most loyal thing you can do for your organizations is call out bad behavior when you see it. And I wish more organizations and CEOs
或者对更大利益的忠诚，或者对社会的忠诚。所以，我认为有一种举报的方式，这可能是指出你圈子或组织中某人的不当行为，同时仍然感受到一种忠诚感。对某些人来说，你能为组织做的最忠诚的事情就是当你看到不良行为时指出来。我希望更多的组织和首席执行官
put forth that message, which would be something along the lines of part of what it means to be a good citizen is we call each other out. You don't take it personally, but we call each other out. You know, you don't take it personally, but we call out bad behavior. And, you know, I think that's a way to communicate a loyalistic message without curbing people's desire to do the right thing and blow the whistle. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
能提出这样的信息，大致意思是：作为好公民的一部分，就是我们要互相监督。你不要把它当成针对个人，但我们要指出不良行为。你知道，你不要把它当成针对个人，但我们要指出不良行为。而且，你知道，我认为这是一种在不抑制人们做正确事情和举报的愿望的情况下，传达忠诚信息的方式。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. This week, we turn over our unsung hero segment to a listener with an episode from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. Today's story comes from Veej Barry.
我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quarelle、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。本周，我们将我们的无名英雄环节交给一位听众，播放我们姐妹播客《我的无名英雄》中的一集。今天的故事来自Veej Barry。
Veej has mild cerebral palsy. Because of the disease, she occasionally trips and falls. One day, in 2017, she was in Washington, DC for an important meeting. That morning in June, it was bright and beautiful. I felt very confident in what I was wearing. I was walking along El Street toward my meeting. And without warning, I fell. I fell badly. I fell on my face. My glasses cut into my eyelid. My cheeks were torn up. I was bleeding. All I wanted to do was jump up and grab my glasses and avoid any further embarrassment.
Veej患有轻度脑瘫。由于这种疾病，她偶尔会绊倒。2017年的一天，她在华盛顿特区参加一个重要的会议。那天六月的早晨，阳光明媚，非常美丽。我对自己的穿着感到非常自信。我正沿着El街走向会议地点。毫无预兆地，我摔倒了。我摔得很重。我脸朝下摔倒了。我的眼镜割伤了眼睑。脸颊被划破了。我在流血。我只想跳起来抓住眼镜，避免进一步的尴尬。
I heard a voice from the man I had noticed earlier standing in a garage. I thought he was a garage attendant. He ran over to me and picked me off the sidewalk, and he walked me, rushed me actually into a building, and down an office hallway, and I heard him yelling, Mary, Mary, come, it's emergency. Veejlada found out the man's name was Kevin. And he rushed me into a bathroom, and Mary appeared, and Mary was the building concierge.
我听到一个男人的声音，我之前注意到他站在车库里。我以为他是车库管理员。他跑过来把我从人行道上扶起来，他带着我，实际上是冲进了一栋大楼，穿过办公走廊，我听到他大喊：Mary，Mary，快来，是紧急情况。Veej后来发现那个男人的名字叫Kevin。他把我冲进洗手间，Mary出现了，Mary是楼里的礼宾员。
Mary took over, and Kevin ran for her first date kit and Mary just automatically even though I had left a trail of blood, she took over washing me, washing my face, washing my hair, trying to get the blood off my clothes, soothing me, I was babbling, I was so embarrassed. But more than that, I was deeply demoralized that this had happened to me yet again, and at what an awful moment I needed to be somewhere very important. And yet here I was a mess. What would have happened had they not picked me off the sidewalk? And here she was trying to bandage me, to make me look somewhat presentable and encourage me that it was going to be all right. Between the two of them, Kevin and Mary, they put me together.
Mary接手了，Kevin跑去拿急救箱，Mary自动地，尽管我留下了一串血迹，她还是接手帮我清洗，洗脸，洗头发，试图把衣服上的血迹洗掉，安慰我，我当时语无伦次，我太尴尬了。但更重要的是，我感到深深的沮丧，因为这种事又发生在我身上，而且是在这样一个糟糕的时刻，我需要去一个非常重要的地方。然而，我却成了一团糟。如果他们没有把我从人行道上扶起来会发生什么？她在这里试图给我包扎，让我看起来体面一点，并鼓励我一切都会好起来的。在Kevin和Mary两人的帮助下，他们让我恢复了状态。
And I was mildly presentable. They didn't think about cleaning up the hallway first. They thought about me. In the end, Vige made it to her meeting. Afterwards, she wrote a letter about Kevin and Mary's actions and sent it to Mary's boss, a woman named Linda. She told me I made her day, but it was uplifting to me, just to write that letter as it is to make this recording right now, and remember the kindness and the real care and the love
我看起来稍微体面了一些。他们没有先考虑清理走廊。他们考虑的是我。最后，Veej赶上了她的会议。事后，她写了一封关于Kevin和Mary行为的信，并寄给了Mary的老板，一位名叫Linda的女士。她告诉我，我让她的一天变得美好，但写那封信对我来说和现在录制这段录音一样令人振奋，并记住了那种善良、真正的关怀和爱，
that was expressed by those two people. Linda told me that she put my letter in the top concierge annual employee awards file for Mary. And I certainly hope Mary got that award that year 2017. Episodes like the one we brought you today take months of research, writing and fact checking. If you enjoyed today's episode, please consider making a contribution to support our work. You can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org.
那是那两个人所表达的。Linda告诉我，她把我的信放进了Mary的年度顶级礼宾员工奖档案中。我当然希望Mary在那一年2017年获得了那个奖项。像我们今天带给您的这一集这样的节目需要数月的调研、写作和事实核查。如果您喜欢今天的节目，请考虑捐款支持我们的工作。您可以在support.hiddenbrain.org进行捐款。再说一遍，是support.hiddenbrain.org。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是Shankar Vedantam。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。